j'ai créé il ya un an les éditions la
plume et le parchemin donc je publie mes
textes mais aussi des textes d'autres
auteurs d'ici et d'ailleurs
et je fais aussi des ateliers en fait
pour les plus jeunes l'objectif premier
en fait c'est d'aider à la lutte contre
l'illettrisme
et donc voilà partir du livre pour
montrer que qu'un deal ne peut pas enfin
peut
devenir
autre chose donc fait venir un field de
venir
une
une bande dessinée on va repartir sous
l'oeil
sur différents projets en fait dans 2014
j'ai un deux trois auteurs touchent moi
ça fait 4 et pour 2015 j'en ai presque
une dizaine donc voilà il ya un fait à
log qui promet d'être assez riche alors
en fait les gens me voient leurs textes
que j'envoie à mon comité donc qui va
qui valait le le lire et ensuite en
paieront fiche pour pour me dire quels
sont les points forts quels sont les
points faibles
c'est un long parcours quand on quand on
est qu était qu'on veut faire publier et
que c'est parfois pas facile
il ya souvent quelques déboires à
essuyer avant de pouvoir y parvenir et
puis on finalement j'ai trouvé la maison
d'édition localement
j'ai décidé faire confiance et marie
danielle pour ça elle réglée gagner ça
fait aucun doute parce que à la base
c'est une hauteur comme moi et qui qui a
décidé de se lancer seul dans l'aventuré
non pas seulement de l'édition mais de
la création d'entreprise de la création
d'une maison d'édition qui qui regroupe
quand même plusieurs corps de métiers
moi ça fait huit ans que j'écris
malheureusement pour mes premiers livres
les éditeurs ne moment pas vraiment
suivi en fait aux prunes aucune pub
aucun suivi j'ai été blessé tout seul
donc j'ai dû tout faire tout seul et
j'ai rencontré d'autres auteurs en fait
qui étaient ensuite dans le même cas et
là je me suis dit si je peux tout faire
moi même l'envoûtant créée voilà une
structure fiable en fait pour c'est pour
ces jeunes gens là
est la personne à qui je fais ma vie mon
courage me suis en fait il ya un temps
pour tout j'ai un temps pour travailler
j'ai un temps pour être
ça vous a un peu peur au début quand
poitou société j'imagine mais au final
l'idée
d'emmener le monde fantastique à la
réunion franchement c'était
plutôt une superbe idée
principalement vu que c'est un projet on
va dire
hors du commun la réunion des gens donc
juste pour ça
ça change donc je pense que pour ça il
mérite de gagner elle est à fond dedans
tous ces chevaux en non-stop donc voilà
mérite
ce que ça représente pour moi en fait ce
challenge mais déjà c'est un c'est un
défi
et puis
j'espère j'espère vraiment que ça
m'aidera à montrer aux gens que voilà
ici sur l'île ont mis au capable de
faire ce genre de choses on est capable
d'aller plus loin et j'aimerais pouvoir
exporter ce que je fais donc pour moi
j'aimerais que ce soit un tremplin en
fait participé au prix du public voter
pour votre candidat favori jusqu'au 27
novembre sur www.cc 9 7 4 points faire
et la page facebook challenge des
créateurs
et